it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
[Music]
this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Music]
it's Friday night at Comic Con so let's
babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin Smith and
I'm Ralph Garman
let's babble the [ __ ] con because it's
comic-con or is it coming god spent too
much time with shatner today do it you
do yours god no comic-con coming how's
everybody doing you have an exhausting
Friday yeah thank God y'all get to sit
down except these poor [ __ ] in
the back they're like we're still
standing you like the Bruce Springsteen
of Con attendees man they can't knock
you down well for well done god bless
you people we will do nothing tonight
that warrants that ovation that you just
gave us I want you to know prepared to
be disappointed this is a historical
show man this is the first time we've
ever done it outside of Hollywood yeah
our first away game it really is and
nowhere more appropriate than here Ralph
because only down in San Diego at this
time of year can you get away with
telling some of the jokes we will tell
tonight I'm talking about references to
like [ __ ] max rebo you know yeah
don't even go all the way over here but
there's still a pocket or some you can
make Commissioner Gordon [ __ ]
bat-mite jokes and people will
understand as opposed to like we do it
up at the Love it's people you make a
bat might [ __ ] Commissioner Gordon
joke people like what what are you
talking about yeah here it plays kind of
yeah or not where's uh where's your
backstage pass you're not wearing the
pink triangle like I am look at you
you're mark they're coming for you next
I'm wearing a pink triangle reefer ray
finds the show up and take me to the
showers tell him about the chicken
well people thanks for coming out it
means here's the thing there's so much
you can do in this town during comic-con
it for you guys to take out some time
and spend it with us tonight means a lot
and we really do appreciate it and that
is the last kind thing I will say all
night I promise because this is my first
drink in three days and I am [ __ ]
ready and as the ever sweet to his ever
salty I am super baked so I'm ready to
be pleasant
however we are at a bar man is it
possible get a frou-frou drink can I get
a pina colada please yes light on the
rum thank you sometimes I wonder why
we're friends I really do because I'm
womanly that hurts
I think womanly drinks like a womanly
boobs you know the rum drink with the
coconut and the milk less of the alcohol
at least I didn't order a Cosmo an
appletini could have been worse all
right we're gonna do some shout outs
tonight I don't do you [ __ ] are all
over the place so I don't know if you're
gonna be here tonight or not so I'm just
gonna pretend that you are and just
power through even if I don't hear you
scream out okay how about big Steve is
big Steven with big Steve's big Steve is
back oh that's right I forgot you were
off yeah our theme song come on James
here's well I'm here brother give it up
for DJ James bad
I'm here the shoutouts theme is new so
forgive me but I forgot we've got a
brand new shout out of him and how how
remiss at me let's rock it
it's shout out Kevin Brown so get your
[ __ ] out
get you caca yeah it's a [ __ ] out Ralph
and cab my name is big Steve and I will
be attending the show on the 22nd in San
Diego with my friend Matt your you Matt
[Music]
did you think it was an ironic nickname
yeah I didn't want me [ __ ] Steve look
how big he is I did not want to assume
dude look I had an organization come up
to me and assume I was big and I never
want to do that to anybody
Yeah right the airplanes you and me
we're terrified of the sky thank you sir
for the shot by the way I'm assuming
it's Jack oh it sure is hold on a second
just a little behind the ears I took a
cab here so [ __ ] the law you're not
getting me tonight Johnny Law you know
big to ask like where it came from
somebody hands you an open beverage and
you're like I hope he roofied you Ralph
now that will teach you a lesson if he
did he wasted a roofie cuz I'll [ __ ] you
for nothing I mean I am I'm a [ __ ] of
the biggest kind cuz at Comic Con it's
not gay that's right if you start
defining a line between what's game
what's not gay at Comic Con you could be
here all day really totally free pass
all these dudes at comic-con it's like
going to prison it's not gay doesn't
happen you do what you have to do to
survive Comic Con yeah and you do what
you have to do to come and you know all
right where were we big Steve and Matt
here we go yes why are you so eager to
hear you wrote this you know what it
says he's like oh I can't wait to hear
what I said to you you know what this is
in here alright because the guy was
drunk
big Steve says attending the 22nd show
in San Diego's my friend Matt we're from
Cincinnati Ohio
go Cincinnati relax can't cheer a town
it's ridiculous Matt just graduated from
college and is now a licensed game nurse
so get your Kaka House is that is is
that of course they teach at your
college I mean can the straight people
go there and become gay nurses or you're
not really a nurse or gay okay I think
it's like like the James Bond license to
kill his license gainer stay below 69
big Steve ads I don't mean blows all
right what do you want a cookie I just
want a little acknowledgement Steve ads
I don't mean all nurses are gay just
Matt and the gay ones excellent point
Steve if you could give him a shout-out
as Sean Connery and tell him what he's
in for that would be tits what yes you
are they should call you loud Steve
instead of big Steve we're playing a
drinking game yeah we should play the
drink games I wish we had an impression
he's essentially gonna drink I wish we
had brought the rules tonight because
there are many of them do you really
find a Xerox machine and hand them out
to the kids will you maybe give a shout
out as Sean Connery and some was he's in
four that would be the tits but listen
he's not really a nurse that he's not
gay how am I supposed to tell him what
he's in for I don't know what he's in
for
he's gay and he's a nurse all right
so Matt you're a gay nourish are you
congratulations your baby do a lot of
prostate exams that'll turn you on you
gain nurse and when fellows get their
appendectomy is you can shave their
[ __ ] you gain nurse such a cheap cheap
way to get out but I know excellent
appropriate at comic-con yeah
how about Joel Sampson is he in the
house Joseph [ __ ] Joel Sampson in the
front row [ __ ]
hello is Joe Sam's in the front row he's
a one-man cheering section
he's here with Mike Paul and Lynn well
they didn't say [ __ ] man he was like
yeah why what happened
Lynn he replaced Lynn all right house
but who's with the chick said row what
you're going to see what you were all
together so he says your name and you're
the only one that cheers your friends
are just like Oh God
oh now we've been noticed what is this
[ __ ] show they never been here
Babylon virgins oh oh oh thank you means
I'm welcome it's not a piña colada by
the way I could tell you from here I can
tell anything with salt on the rim and
is clear is not a pina colada
it's fruity matt is a tea a tequila
sunrise I'm guessing all right I'll give
it a shot you're gonna be nude by the
end of the show if you drink
and I'm gonna be balls deep inside you
what why why because I'm also an avocado
fair enough
I'm here with Mike Paul and Lynn didn't
show because she has taste so this guy
took her place since this is San Diego
comic-con I was wondering what your
all-time favorite comic book moments in
the past have been he asks my personal
favorite was an issue of Ultimates where
Hawkeye escapes his captors by killing
them by flinging his fingernails at them
I didn't read that issue that's sweet I
remember and I remember reading in the
Marvel Universe handbook they described
you know their powers and [ __ ] and they
talked about bullseye and they were like
anything in his hand he's such a deadly
marksman anything in his hands can be
lethal yes and they showed the dude
holding a playing card and that captured
my imagination like could you imagine
you're just hanging out and somebody it
was like flip cut your jugular like I'm
dying and he had a [ __ ] playing card
you would never see that coming
no I'm like a good weapon yeah that
frightened me so I that reminds me of
that but I wouldn't say that was my
favorite moment hands down I think my
all-time favorite moment in comics is in
daredevil born again so as a splash page
and it's right a Karen page is about to
be killed and it's suddenly I don't know
I'm spoilers if you've never read the
born-again storyline it's amazing Karen
page is about to be killed about to fix
fix up with a big old heroin injection
is gonna kill her and [ __ ] and all of a
sudden a billy club comes out of nowhere
and strikes the dude who's about to
attack her and it's like Matt Murdock
who's been missing and assumed crazy and
[ __ ] like that
it's a single-page spread of him holding
her and she's just like crying full of
joy I know that I should be below as
somebody beatin the [ __ ] out of somebody
else but this always [ __ ] touch me
whenever I think of comics I think about
that moment it's so weird cuz he wasn't
even in costume he was just dressed like
himself the [ __ ] we can only get away
with here this weekend
what's yours do it your all-time
favorite comic book moment
I got so many but I think it still has
to be the Jim Aparo shot of Batman
holding Robins lifeless body in a tire
yeah a death in the family where a Jason
Todd dies and and Batman's holding the
body I thought that was still that was
even though a what he's back I know
[ __ ] comic books well he was back but
as of the reboot in the reboot from
issue 1 September he comes back
wait wait wait speedy is still Arsenal
even in the reboot how can that be if
they're rebooting I am I am gonna kick
DC right in the balls and I fly the DC
flag I know you're more of a Marvel guy
i know i'm a DC guy all the way
Batman's my all-time favorite favorite
I've always been a DC guy but they're
just making it so hard to defend them I
mean 52 I got it yes it was very
impressive but not every [ __ ] thing
has to be an event Geoff Johns I have to
write a 19,000 F page epic about every
event that happens right I could tell
you very angry about this right I'll
tell you what man a lot of people been
upset about the reboot I haven't I've
been too saying like look at their
characters they could do whatever they
want people got to remember there was a
Golden Age and everybody thought they
knew all their characters and every
story there was to be told and then one
day it flipped and became the Silver Age
and all those Golden Age stories went
away right and the Silver Age became
prominent then one day that was flipped
by the modern age and all that Silver
Age stuff went out the window when we've
been in the midst of the modern age for
a good 20 year period at least now now
we're entering the digital age where
apparently they're gonna dial it back to
one on everything and kind of reboot the
universe they're not our characters that
they're characters and if they want to
do that with them fine but this bugs the
[ __ ] out of me because yeah see but well
because everything what do you feel
personally about yes of course you know
when they came from my neighbor I said
nothing one of those
but this bugs me because you're telling
me that like if they're rebooting from
one they can't be a [ __ ] speedy or
Arsenal because Green Arrow's whole
[ __ ] adventure hasn't happened yet
those bastards wait all of Batman's
continuity is there some issue one of
Batman doesn't begin with like my
parents are [ __ ] dead again no is it
still Batman Incorporated where he's
franchising dude you should have your
own podcast really we're we're leaving
it up you've got all the inside
information shut the [ __ ] up man
[Applause]
thank you for that info oh you're very
useful but yeah yeah no one listening to
this who cares yeah I was I was very
invested but we got to put on a show
right we're gonna leave afterwards and
we'll smoke poke potty talk oh did you
say well smoke I told you my first drink
in four days I'm a little I'm a little
bit light weight yeah so those are our
favorite comic book moments to answer
your question so that was a long round
about fun so to sum up those were are my
favorite moments this case you want to
cut that entire [ __ ] question of the
podcast I just wanted to a man leave it
in Melancon cold how about a me and
Jared or a me and Jared in the house
this is amazing I showing up three it's
cuz the theme song they're like we got
our [ __ ] out back at the lovage where
you can park and get to the club easily
people don't [ __ ] show up these
people worked hard to get here you do
show up I know who's Anson Adi I know
okay see here the chick she goes we love
San Diego
that's funny Amy and Jared this is from
Amy welcome to my hometown of San Diego
all right we're all in favor of San
Diego you don't need to cheer it I don't
know if you know this but you love sandy
no [ __ ]
I'll be the show the 22nd boyfriend
Jared he introduced me to your show and
I've been hooked ever since of this
shout-out is for him it's very sweet Amy
we come here to celebrate our
anniversary but our anniversary isn't
for our first date or our first kiss or
even the first time we said I love you
to one another it was the first time we
met got plastered and [ __ ] stand up
stand up stand up you two all right all
right you know it's you're not the
[ __ ] Amish guy wait wait wait show us
how you did it all right easy was it all
the same night you met got plastered and
[ __ ] all the same now oh that's that
expect how long rows this how long what
I this is six years ago right on man
look at that there's a [ __ ] total
wonderful advertisement for casual
unsafe sex with a strap well they went
through the stages then they became
friends with benefits they [ __ ] and
then they became must be friends but
keep [ __ ] em no no they [ __ ] they
became a horrible movie
then eventually something a little more
serious happened just like in the movie
six years later here we are celebrating
the closest thing we have to an
anniversary hopefully laughing our asses
off then maybe ending the night drunk
and naked just for nostalgic purposes
well there's more purposes than that
purposes of orgasm that would she be
your purposes can you please in your
Harrison Ford voice tell Jared happy
anniversary and that if I'm drunk enough
and he's lucky enough he just might find
out what Princess Leia really meant by
into the garbage chute flyboy
[Applause]
ami adds yes that would be a really
nerdy reference to anal sex this is the
greatest weekend of my life just tanker
in the back see the Millennium Falcon
shitty dick wait wait mr. Ford while you
have their attention don't forget to
plug boys an alien oh stop save it for
the end that's what my wife says is that
did that do it is he gonna get it after
after that stage er what's the next
stage she's got to get drunk enough how
many drinks have you I want to make sure
this happens just one oh come on girl
always remember comic-con man the comic
guns a horrible place where you hurt my
hiney
even our marriage only last night when I
gave up the garbage chute it was
supposed to be a Star Wars joke you took
it seriously
Threepio get us out of here oh my
goodness he's dying inside of her
[ __ ] that's no moon it's a trap this
is from grant from Australia grant from
Sydney Australia in the house you ruined
my [ __ ] perfect record yeah we were
on a streak man everyone hates you grant
if you're listening to this he's from
Sydney Australia really quickly I just
wanted to mention it that he wanted to
give a shout out he's a first time out
of Australia apparently is here in San
Diego for the comic-con so he wanted to
give a shout out to his friends dear
friends back in Sydney who will be
listening to this next week when it
posts and their names are Mitch death
and Courtney print and those are their
real names Mitch death name is death
it's so weird because that's death as
his last name yes and his parents were
like Mitch takes this thing out of it if
you meet the Grim Reaper and his name's
Mitch you don't mind going totally if I
if my name was death I name my kid
horrible
just as a walking constant reminder man
people like you know [ __ ] Sally Jones
horrible death yeah they went the other
way
[ __ ] sing along with Mitch death
alright it's time for some emails from
all around the world James hit me
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions this comes
from the UK Kate in Devon in England
says I've been listening to HBO from the
start and I've tried to convert as many
people as possible to become garmi
strong well thank you k garmi strong
calm by the way is where you can buy
your t-shirts for HP the latest
candidate is my dad kate says there's
just one problem every time I try to
play him some clips of the show my
iTunes seems to land on all the
references to Anil not hard to do with
our show - every desperate plea from a
guy for his girlfriend to give up the
balloon not and every random girl who's
offering up their rusty bullet hole or
ion cannon or asteroid we had targets
bigger than that was that one brats line
wasn't whopper oh yeah
could you please tell my dad who's a big
fan of clerks and Sharktopus well he's
got good taste yeah put those together
Clark - puss flirt - puss all right for
[ __ ] hit somebody you got to do one more
film it's gotta be called clerk to play
Sam you do it do it take the line damn
you click - puss
half clerk half octopus all killer just
because he kills you doesn't mean he
liked you he's not even supposed to be
here today
good you tell my dad and your finest Al
Pacino voice that Babylon isn't all
about anal just 75% she adds in the
parentheses Oh
Kate's dad Oh your daughter she likes it
dirty
oh come on now you got a no she's taking
all her male suitors right in the hiney
come on now oh that's what she says when
she takes it in the pooper oh I think
she she wanted you to convince her dad
to listen to the show I think that's a
commercial I had to kill himself I can't
because those two [ __ ] talk about
[ __ ] and butts all the time come on now
oh come on with the sphincters
thank you madam I almost forgot how to
do my impression
she loves San Diego it's like it was on
stage I forgot my line no why Wow she's
like your Cyrano de Bergerac today I
appreciate Caitlyn riding in today
Caitlyn gives me a little love which I
appreciate because you usually poopoo
all over this this little bit Ralph I
was catching up on my podcast and I just
want to tell you how awesome it is when
you sing Edelweiss that's right I
encourage it I'm always happy to hear
you do around to beta lies do it here I
know it's your [ __ ] sick dream to
sing Edelweiss at Comic Con or something
like that
Caitlin writes when I was little that
song was a standard on my dad's lullaby
repertoire ah hearing you sing it
brought back a lot of great memories
Olivia which is name of my little girl
is so lucky to have you as a dad and I
promise that hearing you sing from the
Julie Andrews collection will keep her
off the pole maybe I don't want her off
the pole I have no problem with making a
living on the pole true yeah
you better start singing a device quick
[Music]
will you [ __ ] kidding me over there
singing along that's what happens do
when you go out on the road and sing a
concert and [ __ ] you sing part of the
verse and then the audience takes over
yeah like at a u2 song with like
like that [ __ ] okay come up here and
join me on stage let's sing it together
you and I no come on
yeah you and me doing it together we'll
do it as you do it mix things up a
little bit come on Maria von Trapp make
some play clothes out of curtains and
sit your ass down and sing with me
what's your name what's your name Ashley
you ready you ready to sing a little
voice with me
I'm terrible well I'm not far off so
[Music]
soft and white clean and bright you look
happy to meet me
Ashley everybody Ashley oh absolutely
[Music]
well done well done oh I want to sing
badly and hug to this young lady said
hey guys love the podcast I know we got
to talk about what you just did never
eject me for my [ __ ] seat again
couldn't we have handled that backstage
after the show no man I'm gonna start
picking co-host right in the middle of
bits left and right Jim sir come up here
and talk about Liam Neeson's [ __ ] with
me I just thought you'd be more
comfortable sitting and singing that you
would standing I apologize Kevin I had
no idea broke my heart move on well
welcome to the last Hollywood babble-on
I hope you're all happy this is where it
all falls apart this is what happens
when we go on
[Music]
[Applause]
David Banner here walks down the street
alone give that [ __ ] penis a sandwich
well the end like we began they were
fine until they played Comic Con their
team broke up that was like Martin and
Lewis yeah this comes from Adam Welles
in Minneapolis Minnesota guys love the
podcast listening to you to make fun of
the idea of Arnold Schwarzenegger in a
Western we did do that last week he's
supposed to do a Western is his next
film made me want to point out that this
has already happened Hal Needham
directed a movie released in 1979 called
the villain it stars Kirk Douglas and
Margaret and Arnold Schwarzenegger
Arnold's character's name is handsome
stranger yes his actual character's name
is handsome stranger the movie also
stars Paul Lin as a Native American
chief named nervous elk nervous elk
because they would [ __ ] the elk that's
why they're nervous is that were and it
was Paul Lin yeah honey yeah I wouldn't
[ __ ] it myself you have a Paul Lynde
impression yeah
man here's a scene where Schwarzenegger
and Margaret are riding in a buckboard
and Schwarzenegger is doing his best
cowboy impression please enjoy
[Music]
you're gonna be sick
what do you mean Wow
spectacular you're gonna want to hear
the directors like okay Arnold here the
horses need to go faster so you go yah
yah ah ah no no it's yeah yeah okay
we'll just go with that yeah that'll
work was that Ann Margaret that was and
Margaret next to him yeah
and Margaret you want to see my pecker
have my baby
Joseph writes from Chile you're not even
gonna grade that impression dude I so
rarely step into a character I've
stepped into Arnold I imagine you have
been like a great it's a something you
wrote right over I I was I was you don't
even know it was Arnold no I did Joseph
from Chile writes we got an email from
Chile
my wife is four it stopped cheering for
Chile to Ashley for God's sake so far
it's been Cincinnati San Diego and Chile
now I'd love to eat chili in San Diego
whoo
Rafa Kevin my wife is four months
pregnant we found out last week she's
carrying a boy he'll be our second I
called my mom in the UK to give her the
good news and when she asked if we had
thought of any names I suggested a few
names which were all meant by stony
silence until I mentioned Ralph she
flat-out told me I'm not having a
[ __ ] Ralph in my family
why are you laughing at that they're
going please don't tell me she's gonna
maim this poor kid Ralph
I got sensibility in paragraph two she
suggested I never mentioned the name
again
love the show guys yeah well [ __ ] you
Joseph sending me hurtful emails this
one comes from Steve Nash not the
basketball player yet I walk through my
apartment the other day and it came upon
my girlfriend watching charmed I
typically ignore the show due to the
fact it's a pile of ostrich [ __ ] anyway
while walking to the kitchen I heard a
familiar voice coming from the
television upon inquiring upon this
recognizable voice who sham nice whom
should I see none other than Ralph
Garman for the first time I live by sat
to watch the show only wishing to get
more Ralph in my life you were on for a
maximum of 30 seconds and then I
remembered why this show was a heaping
pile of ostrich [ __ ] he had are you
serious you and [ __ ] charm well last
week we did a bit that Kevin called
garbage
where we talked about my early
struggling acting career I believe it
was Doogie Howser last week yes you see
him that was the gay porn I did yeah it
was close it was you in a locker room
with some other EMTs right in charmed
you know he's exaggerating thirty
seconds I had a much larger role I had a
a recurring role on charmed where I
played the DJ at the p3 for you Charmed
fans you probably member the P 3 P 3 was
the nightclub that the three teenage
witches owned I don't know why they were
teenage witch club owners but it P 3
stood for their names because their
dreams all start with me was prudence
and
pariah and parsnip I never watched the
[ __ ] show I have no idea
just move along you who are you barking
at who me
you what were the names again
prudence true proof page Phoebe
Piper there you go probably four PV
Paige and Piper one of them left right
right then Rose McGowan showed up you
got that out of your system shut the
[ __ ] up
but thank you for your help thank you
for your assistance yes
you could tell it was bugging him so
it's it's time for a segment we call
garbage thanks to Kevin with and someone
said in a jingle they were so enthused
with the the idea of garbage let me hear
the mayor I think James James has it I
hope he does
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yep
that's what that is that is my that's my
acting career reduced to a joke that's
what that is enters with customs for
kind of magnificence though you know
however it still ends with garbage yeah
undercut at the end so here's I think
the episode that Steve Nash was
referring to where I bring out the still
to this day wildly popular band
Dishwalla on stage but you'll notice I
did so well in the first episode and I
put the second episode where after that
I get a second chance where they really
kind of doubled my role really they
expand the role twofold where I get to
bring out these still to this day wildly
popular band The Cranberries so I hope
you'll enjoy this episode of garbage
starring me Ralph Garman on charmed
click click click the did you press that
or not maybe not
see what happens when you play in
another team Stadium yeah you got to
play the field though man
yeah so uh trust me was hilarious
are we serious they're not gonna see
yeah I I don't think so
do you bummer I'll pull it up on my
phone you keep doing the show I'm gonna
watch it on YouTube I was kind of into
it man I think we're jammed up yeah it
jammed up for a minute hang on
just maybe bam bam there we go did you
work with the girls did you in I did I
did I worked with let's see what III I
worked before Rose McGowan came along
so it was shannen doherty right and that
other girl Melissa Milano and then the
third girl Holly combs right Holly call
center and Holly was the only person who
talked to me
Shannen Doherty who knew oh my god we
both worked with shannen doherty yeah
she was probably nicer to you than she
was to me just a touch we're getting
close we've got a giant white screen to
look at it's thinking
and we may have to move on I don't know
if we can wait any longer but there's a
lot of video tonight take that take that
penis away from that sandwich yes all
right let's move on every week we say
goodbye to some people in show business
that we all know and love in this
particular case you none of you here
probably know him or love him but we
have a lot of Australian listeners who
sent in this particular Tinseltown stiff
this week and so we honor him with
Tinseltown sniffs and now another
edition of
[Music]
they will be miss they will indeed his
name was David Nagumo Jarrah David
Nagumo Jarrah
was Australia's most popular indigenous
actor he was an Aborigine okay here's a
picture of him in Crocodile Dundee in
Los Angeles he looks an awful lot like
Batman riding a shark oh yeah yeah he
did a ton of movies he did rabbit-proof
fence which is a huge hit in Australia
black-and-white ned kelly Crocodile
Dundee in LA as we mentioned kangaroo
jack he was found at the age of 44 in a
park near Fremantle near Perth and then
he passed away police said they are not
looking into it because his death was
not suspicious he was found in a park at
44 they didn't say his death was
suspicious but they were like it might
have been fun because you're in the park
man maybe you just had too much fun the
parents always telling you slow down
pace yourself
maybe this guy slowed down too much yeah
this guy went crazy you and croak about
too soon you might want to file 44 years
old here is that the second pick of
David in Australia that it's most recent
film with Hugh Jackman 44 yeah that
looks holy [ __ ] much older than 44 what
are the Aborigines doing out there to
make you look like that at 44 a gym
quick hard living I'm gonna put him on
my fridge so when I feel bad about
myself I go well still look at him at 44
I look better than that though does one
of our favorite new segments is a little
something we like to call [ __ ] that
should not be we've done a bunch of them
we did that Back to the Future 3 where
that kid pointed to his penis that was
Jedi were Harrison Ford grabbed Carrie
Carrie Fisher's boob the Harry Potter
map where people are [ __ ] Teen Wolf
Raiders Lost Ark rebelling wolf you
might have seen a dick yeah where does
the Lost Ark was Bela the bug Last
Samurai was Tom Cruise's horse kick
somebody in the ball right well people
have been sending this in over and over
and over again and I'm always like well
everyone knows about this one everybody
has seen this one but we are at Comic
Con I thought if we're gonna show it yes
well first of all we need the video to
work wouldn't we so he's gonna say I
can't believe you're getting ready for
this we don't even know if we've got it
[Music]
maybe BAM they're storm trooper hitting
his head in the doorway never gets old
[Music]
hey [ __ ] up that became so famous that
Lukas when he went back and redid the
film's put the sound effect in when the
guy hit the wall
yeah puts a clunk in a sound effect when
the stormtrooper hits his head on the I
would have thrown in a line like aren't
you a little tall for a stormtrooper
he's like yes that's why I just hit the
door new releases this weekend two new
movies in theaters everywhere
friends-with-benefits after you guys
have seen it no do you know what the
premises let me think
I'm thinking Justin Timberlake and Mila
Kunis are real - really smoking hot
attractive people who apparently can't
find love and so they're friends and
they decide to have sex with no
emotional ties whatsoever that's oh I
see I figured that out from the trailers
yeah yeah and then chaos ensues and and
emotions flare up and they fall in love
I'm fair enough
I just there's a running commentary are
you just literally do a commentary on
this bits man every time we talk she's
like trying to avoid all the cliches of
romantic Hollywood movies this plotline
says yes Dylan and Jamie soon discovered
that by adding the act of sex to their
friendship it does lead to complications
the heck you say so in trying to avoid
the cliche Ralph they were in smack-dab
into the middle of it and sucked its
huge [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah right on man well
I'm sure someone's gonna enjoy that they
should have been voided Ashton Kutcher
Natalie Portman movies is what they
should have done it seems like I just
saw this moved out six months ago and
Captain America the First Avenger also
who saw it how many people here saw it
wow that's not the rest of you haven't
gone yet Wow
it was well I thought it was totally
elegant made you guys enjoy it it's very
well done
although there's one section I'm
certainly not being critical of it that
I was not expecting at all the by war
section that was [ __ ] crazy was that
I thought it was genius you liked it I
loved I'm not saying I didn't like it
but all of a sudden you're watching my
catamarans spoilers but you're watching
Captain America becomes that he gets the
serum and it becomes the supersoul Chris
Evans he goes from me and CG Chris Evans
to like look at my pecs by the way how
amazing is that special effect where
they make Chris Evans to a scrawny
little dude it's cool but like he was
bitching about wanting to be bigger and
I was like I wish they would do that to
me just make me smaller you know but and
so after he gets buff and he becomes big
and they you know he can become Captain
America instead he winds up going out on
the road to sell war bonds for like they
say 200 performances and it's cool they
put him in the you know the classic
classic Captain America kind of you know
outfit you would see Roman the you know
the aisles here I guess but at the same
time it goes on for a few minutes and
you're just like what what happened they
take they step aside to do a musical
like a Busby Berkeley you saw yeah that
was the only thing I thought was weird
you thought it was cool that was great
why because I thought it made sense of
why he would put that costume on when he
went into battle
I thought if he just came out like a
super soldier why wouldn't he just gear
him up with the traditional standard
helmet and the and the suit and
everything and put him out in the battle
why would he wear that blue and red
white and blue costume this way he had
already established himself as an icon
and when he went into battle that's why
he said give me the specially painted
helmet and all that kind of stuff all
right fair enough ox of that man I
thought was smart on their part to
explain away why this guy wears bright
dayglo colors into battle apparent where
they could easily find you to shoot at
you but why does everything have to be
explained can't they be like he put on
the suit just because it's [ __ ]
badass you know I don't need an
explanation like a 5 minute like all
this [ __ ] happened his mom [ __ ] died
a seal exploded on the beach Jesus
showed up and then that's why he wears
the outfit you know even more eager to
be in the action in the front lines
because he felt because he was being he
became a clown
for their amusement Henry what am i a
clown for your amusement
that's what he was feeling totally but I
dug it the movie then kind of I loved it
I mean I think I'm more than you know
yeah yeah and then the Avengers I mean
they end insanely well the movie ends
you got to sit through all the credits
if you're going to see it make sure you
sit through all the credits and you know
with all the Marvel movies they put a
little coda at the end and the Thor coda
I wasn't too wild about it was the first
one was like blah but this one was
[ __ ] astounding it was the Avengers
teaser
so essentially you get to see footage
from the Avengers movie and it is it you
just sit there looking at it and you're
not even thinking or moving or touching
anything and suddenly you're like and
you just [ __ ] flood dude you would
literally come yourself no yeah yeah I
wasted generations of children watching
that trailer man inadvertently it was
just like because you see them together
one put the last shot
you see Thor standing there in the midst
of the them at all the count at the
conference table even a huge Marvel guy
and I saw that I was like someone got it
right credits totally I did the movie
how clever was it to have them to have
Howard Stark be one of the guys in the
film who is like the technological
genius and then in the next film he's
gonna be working with Howard's kid
basically Tony Stark is Robert Downey
jr. nice little tie-in that's gonna be
for them oh yeah well it's comic books
they have that continuity thing they
love to do that interconnect everything
it's very clever for Captain America to
tie that in I know the performances were
good at the Yugo weaving was great is
that Chris Evans who's Evans great I
thought I think most people were kind of
worried that when he was cast as Captain
America because they know him as the
Human Torch and the Human Torch is
always quippy and [ __ ] one line suck
my dick Ben Grimm and [ __ ] like that
and I don't remember that now is the
best line in the second Fantastic Four
um but but then so going into this you
expect he'll be kind of that as well but
played it completely differently it was
very earnest very uh sincere as a moment
in the movie I thought was really
beautiful where are the doctors just
like why he want to go over to Germany
to kill a bunch of Nazis I take it and
he goes no sir I don't want to kill
anybody I just don't like bullies yeah
and you're like oh he you now that line
you nail that character you nail the
rest so he now that a Steve Rogers and
his cap was really earnest I thought he
did a great [ __ ] job me too yeah he
did he did really nice job moving on
with the HBO headlines Rebecca Black is
back in the news this week
you may remember her from branding
branding she's got a brand new single
that dropped this week called Maine
mommy mommy this song is about all the
haters who dumped on the 14 year old
singer when she became an overnight
sensation oh that's sweet she wrote a
song about me there's a new video a new
song apparently she's putting out an EP
because she's not touted enough to sing
an entire albums worth of songs and
she's putting out herself without the
help of a record label in the artist man
indeed she is roots I dig the I brought
in a copy of the video a little of her
in the video I know I look I'm hoping
it'll work
[Music]
[Applause]
in all fairness though whoever his
manager did spend a lot of time and
expense to prove that she can't dance
either
I think it's kind of catchy this is my
mom and it's I'm oh man Ralph this is no
no yeah it's not it's not bad enough to
be interesting anymore that's her
problem she's mediocre now and mediocre
gets ignored so I never understood why
people were so pissed off at that first
song I thought I was single and hideous
no it was honestly no worse than like
most [ __ ] pop songs she does sing
about cereal this is fat man I
appreciated her singing about cereal all
right she was in your wheelhouse when I
the first [ __ ] piece of music I heard
in the radio in years where I was like
roll the tear cuz I'm like I hear you
man
you gotta eat you gotta figure out where
it is gonna ball crunch sure yeah I'm
glad she's keeping going she's like [ __ ]
all you people I keep saying I'm
talentless stop supporting the bed I
have to I'm talentless I've been doing
it nearly 20 years man
why can't she enjoy a little [ __ ]
time of the Sun easy there easy did you
hear that
oh I expected somebody come running in
with dynamite strapped to their chests
that made me think about the panel I
hosted today we did 30 minutes or less
the new comedy with Jesse Eisenberg Aziz
Ansari and the premise is to guys need
money so they two bad guys so they
picked some poor kid who's a pizza
delivery guy and they strapped a bomb to
his chest and say if you don't go and
rob a bank we're gonna blow you up
that's the comic premise and I know it
doesn't sound funny inherently but the
movie is actually very funny but I did a
panel with Sony and all of their films
today I don't know if you can tell I'm
walking on clouds or not but Emily's one
more time
Emma Stone did you just did you just
call her Emily that's my pet name for
her when we're in bed but I I met Emma
Stone today that's what I'm saying
and people always write in they say you
guys talk some you guys Ralph always
talks so much about Emma Stone Emma
Stone Oh
does she know has fat friends told her
does she aware what's going on
well I'm here to tell you that she
absolutely does not know who I am
no clue and no idea Marc Webb however
who directed the amazing spider-man he
is a big fan of the radio show I do in
Los Angeles in the morning oh yeah I
said great another another doughy
bearded director that's just what I need
I already got one of those I need Emma
Stone I need some zip if you really want
it I'll give you some I'll do that for
you Kristen Stewart got into a accident
this week oh stop it how dare you sirs
you people are [ __ ] hateful the
Twilight star was cruising around in a
Mini Cooper wouldn't he just [ __ ]
know it when a woman in her Mercedes
smashed into her backside it's not the
first time by the way someone's smashed
into her backside according to witnesses
the woman driving the Mercedes seemed
very apologetic while of course
Kristen true to form registered no
emotion on her face whatsoever I felt
pretty good about that Oh big problems
on the set of Cash Cab you guys are Cash
Cab fans what is it you don't know Cash
Cab hence what is it I guess that should
have been a giveaway Cash Cab is a game
show where does a guy and he drives
around New York and you hop in the back
of his cab and he says you're on a game
show and they've got cameras set up in
lights in the in the ceiling and stuff
if you can answer I think I know three
or five trivia question whatever is if
you get it right
he'll take you wherever you want to go
free of charge and you also earn money
but if you if you get them incorrectly
he just pulls over and drops you off
wherever you are when you win you lose
that's Cash Cab it's awesome it's the
greatest game ever because people don't
know they're on a game show and then
suddenly they're honest
anyway Cash Cab was filming in Canada
apparently this week when the person
driving the cab back to the storage
facility after they filmed the show hit
a 61 year old man and killed him
that is sad he will be missed that is
sad but it gave birth a brand new game
called crash Kappa no I'm getting they
didn't really do that but that would be
a great game it's a trivia question
right now we run you over that would be
now that would be a game I would watch
welcome to cash purse come on hey hey a
hearse is where you dead people rise I
think they know I think in the celebrity
sickbay this week Grey's Anatomy star
Eric Dane has entered into rehab
McSteamy Mick Mick Stevie how did you
know that I had to read McSteamy I used
to watch that show
he was McSteamy you and your pina
coladas in your McSteamy yeah can I get
you some medication for your yeast
infection I'm in touch with my feminine
side say what you will
anyway McSteamy went into rehab for
addiction to painkillers apparently he
was so sexy it hurt no no he had a
sports injury he claims and he got
addicted to painkillers and now he's in
rehab and they hope he'll be back to
work soon yeah that's a bummer man they
can't do without McSteamy because then
although left with his McDreamy oh yeah
you know I auditioned for Mick jizzy I
don't know if that was a role they wrote
just for me it was walked the hallways
of the hospital just shooting ropey
strands of jism on patients it was not a
character they chose to keep no I'd like
to think it wasn't my performance as
much as it was just a mistake in writing
I thought they pulled your character out
because there was a legal process thing
yeah they wanted to call you spider mags
you're slinging webs left and right and
they were like that names already taken
and so they wrote your character out
now that the videos working again can we
show me uncharged yeah man I do want to
do that can we revisit that bit James is
that possible James left I'm here I'm
loading it up is that possible because
now it seems like it's working again I
seems like it's working just dawned on
me that maybe we can show the charmed
bit that we didn't get to or the clip is
so bad it won't be played on a lot of
electronics you son of a [ __ ]
yeah how dare you sir there we go let's
see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and one night only benefit for the
animal rights button the cranberry yeah
it could have been just the cranberries
but no they added that whole animal fund
chunk for me did you have to let that
linger don't be a zombie I think we're
out why we talk about music news our
Kelly apparently won't be singing for a
while he adds a severe pain in his
throat they rushed into the hospital
turned out he had an abscess on his
tonsil and they had to perform emergency
surgery on his throat deep throat yeah
it was like I believe my throat's dry
doctors say there's no way of knowing
when he'll it was good what do you want
- got a laugh what boy what do you want
for me I die pause I left you get your
laugh and then I kept going it was good
it was great here's a lightbulb that's
your gift for the funny joke okay
doctors say there's no way of knowing
when he'll sing again but they requested
of art Kelly that he stopped peeing on
underage girls to do with his illness
they just think it's [ __ ] up oh we got
a Lindsay Lohan theme I think we debuted
it last week we have that James lives
alone
why don't you come to your senses
Lyndsey's in the news this week she's
out of jail and by jail I mean here
multi-million dollar beachfront condo
and she's working again she did a photo
shoot for a photographer named Tyler
Shields I brought you a couple pictures
of her photo shoot this is the first one
here no well that's the 44 year old
Aborigine who died there we go this is
this is Lindsay Lohan's oh no I'm sorry
that's her prom photo I'm sorry I
apologize
that's Lindsay's date grabbing her tit
she also shot this shot whichever people
are saying is disturbing cuz she's
holding a bloody knife yeah holding a
bloody knife at the guy on the left hand
side the corpse is playing her career
that's right after she stabbed it to
death she also had to appear in court
this week because the judge of her case
judge Stephanie sought nur said she
can't understand why out of 60 days of
community service that she was sentenced
to so far Lindsay has only completed
four days of community service the judge
said I will give you no extra time to
complete this you must do it in the
allotted time I will hear no excuses she
added especially I was on the set of
that John Gotti movie and that's not a
joke that's actually what she said
Lindsay is also required to enter
counseling but Lindsay says because her
Screen Actors Guild Insurance has run
out she can't get her head fixed it must
be amazing to date her man because
nothing you do will ever be as bad as
everything she does every day
you get away with murder man because if
she was just like oh my god you leave
the toilet seat up all the time I'm like
you're Lindsay Lohan yeah
you're supposed to go for 60 days and
help out battered women and shooting
photos of you stabbing dudes in the
metro station well I've got community
service is hard Ralph it really is but
just [ __ ] do it
yeah that's the model because she
escaped like she dodged a bullet man you
imagine you dodged a bullet you're gonna
put in your time on the on the thing the
one thing they do throw your way but
instead I don't think she gets it no
Lindsay Lindsay's buddy Britney Spears
also in legal news this week her ex
bodyguard Fernando Flores has filed suit
against Britney Spears this is
spectacular
he claims that she was abusive she wants
to tell this kind yes but she was also
abusive there was harassment involved
and it caused him and I quote anxiety
depression and insomnia working for
Britney Spears he only worked for for
four months by the way he is suing her
for ten million dollars in the paperwork
he claims that consistently Britney
Spears his boss would chain smoked
[ __ ] get over it pass gas and pick
her nose unapologetically refused the
day's supposed to apologize for that
kind of thing
I guess not if you're the boss refused
to bathe for days didn't brush your
teeth or use deodorant he claims his
biggest problem was that mr. Flores and
he used to be a police officer used to
work for the police he thought she was
mentally unstable because she would
insist that everyone her staff call her
either
queen bee or Jennifer
her lawyers are claiming that mr. Flores
is simply trying to sully britney
Spears's reputation yes you don't want a
sorry reputation as a white-trash bad
mother who walks barefoot in gas station
bathrooms at each Cheetos
[ __ ] hell ten million dollars that's
it I mean come on man at the end of the
day if you pass a little gas you got to
pay a bill now and [ __ ] like that
you can say oops I did it again
[Applause]
and if I'm working for and I'm sitting
in the car man I'm never giving her lip
she farts him like hit me baby one more
time
[Applause]
madam you're adding nothing to the show
now she's adding real commentary she
literally like button a bit with she's
very lucky and she's right she's kind of
lucky it's just okay Kim Kardashian also
has filed a lawsuit against Old Navy
because she's [ __ ] her way through the
new Navy antonov sorry
now she's suing Old Navy for 15 to 20
million dollars in damages because they
used a woman that Kim Makar - Ian claims
looks identical to her and by doing that
in their commercials they are trying to
dupe the public into thinking that Kim
was affiliated with Old Navy
now the woman's name is Melissa Molinaro
that's her name she's sang and danced
and the commercials the super cute
series of commercials for Old Navy I
think we've got a photo of the two girls
side-by-side nope
there we go they are pretty similar but
there are a lot of differences
Melissa Molinaro is sang and danced in
the commercials which means that she has
talent I think in a court of law you
could prove that that is a substantial
difference between the two of them
however you have to admit there are some
significant similarities like the fact
that I would like to put my penis inside
both of them
I don't know if that'll hold up in court
or not I wonder if Kim Kardashian's
lawsuit has anything to do with the fact
of this small little fine print I read
in the story that Melissa Molinaro the
other woman just happens to be dating
Kim's ex-boyfriend Reggie Bush as we
speak I changed my mind I don't want to
put my penis in both of them quite
frankly because they would it would they
have to Reggie would just be like
throwing a hot dog down a hallway quite
frankly I don't want to embarrass myself
TV news Charlie's Angels big shake-up in
the new Charlie's Angels Robert Wagner
was supposed to be the voice of Charlie
on Charlie's Angels he is out of that
show his representatives claim that he's
got scheduling conflicts
yeah because Robert watch your schedule
is so like an act he's got all those
geriatric insurance commercials to do no
word on who will be the new charlie but
Robert Wagner has been yes I would like
to be Charlie ever what voice would you
do it in if you were Charlie wee oh my
goodness hello angels how are you
today's client is mr. David Stevenson
he's been robbed of all his money don't
you know it's a shame we need to go deep
undercover and find out what's wrong but
remember girls life is for the living
now that's a Charlie's Angels that one
could you imagine like he's done talking
all those three chicks look at each
other and they're like why do we work
for this man more TV news Fran
Drescher's new sitcom happily divorced
is I'm gonna put a [ __ ] hit out on
you in about 20 minutes
you're brutal and is there any guy there
who's with that woman really god bless
you sir
a bunch of dudes that just stepped back
Fran Drescher's got a new sitcom on TV
land it's called happily divorced it's
about it's based on the true story of
her life where she was married to a guy
for 20 years and then he came out and
told her he was gay if you listen to
that voice for 20 years wouldn't you
start sucking [ __ ] too after the law I
think he was fine until he was married
to her and then it all went south a
bigger voice violin yeah
I'm Bobby Flay man you know the sex
would sound like oh my god
and that would be you we can't imagine
what she would sound like oh my god you
kak so small ah anyway it's only been on
for a couple weeks TV land's announced
they've already renewed it for another
season so we've got more French record -
Fran Drescher like the clap will be with
us always Mila Kunis got asked to the
Marine Corps ball by sergeant Scott
Moore yes now they're married no no
dammit Marine corporal Kelsey DeSantis
asked Justin Timberlake to the Marine
Corps ball he said yes so sergeant Ray
Lewis this week thought it'd be a good
idea to put another invitation on
youtube to his favorite actress and ask
her to the U to the marine corps ball he
asked Betty White to be his escort I
brought it a video of Sergeant Ray Lewis
asking Betty out and I oh please
poor James it's coming guys all right
I'd like to take anyway she's just funny
she's sweet she's mature
she's the all-around perfect woman I
really think that we'd have a good time
I'm fine you know I'm going to be
performing I think I could make her
laugh I think she could make me laugh I
think we go laughs together it's it's
gonna be great it's gonna be a good time
Kennedy and her tumor core ball this
year I know what
well sadly Betty White said no to
Sergeant Ray Lewis Betty said it's
because he's black what the oh no I'm
sorry I misread that Betty said I'm
deeply flattered I'd truly appreciate
the invitation unfortunately I cannot
accept as I will be taping an episode of
Hot in Cleveland so Betty
accepts a cleveland steamer but she
won't go out with she won't go out with
charger Ray Lewis that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Betty White
hi say thank God she put her foot down
there was a trend happening where every
celebrity was get invited to a prom man
and a guy only uniform would force the
celebrity to do whatever they want and I
know what it would eventually lead to me
not getting asked and that would hurt
Thanks Walmart is celebrating the 15th
anniversary of South Park
I didn't [ __ ] stutter Walmart is
going to celebrate the 15th anniversary
of South Park they are introducing a new
snack on their shelves called cheesy
poops
which as you know is Eric Cartman's
favorite snack on the show have you ever
been to Walmart you know the people in
wall Mountain need more than anything
more [ __ ] snacks what the [ __ ] I like
going to Walmart just to buy snacks I'm
shake is you goodbye like a garbage can
full of whoppers because you never know
when you're gonna have a whopper party
have you ever dumped your head into a
garbage can full of whoppers Ralph and
just like ah
it's [ __ ] freedom and
say it's the taste of sweet freedom yes
there's a little New Jersey news for my
buddy Kevin Smith who of course is a New
Jersey native Bruce Springsteen one of
the most famous people to come out of
New Jersey the boss has a statue in his
honor in Asbury Park New Jersey for the
birth of of the E Street Band local
residents and Bruce fans call it a
monstrosity
apparently the bust was created by an
artist trained at Princeton University
and that makes people think that
Princeton University doesn't know [ __ ]
all about teaching people art the bronze
bust is supposed to be Springsteen's
head wearing a red bandana I will show
you the photo of it now and you tell me
if that's brief Springsteen wearing a
red bandanna
that's lurch from The Addams Family
it looks like Colonel Kurtz man gone
upriver at best it's the lead singer
from loverboy apparently no one is happy
with it except for the artist everyone
else is upset and they're planning on
removing it soon so he didn't even
commented Springsteen has not commented
no but other people like this songs yeah
it's horrible and it's outside that brie
Park they need to move that to a secret
garden
[Applause]
[Music]
take the bait nope I'm better I'm
drunker all right it's casting news
Dwight Yoakam is gonna be the bad guy in
Lone Ranger fair enough it's gonna be
butch cavendish also added to the cast
Barry Pepper it's gonna play a cavalry
captain named captain Jay fuller and
Helena Bonham Carter will play a crazy
[ __ ] who dresses funny no she's gonna
play a madam who dresses funny who plays
The Lone Ranger
Armie Hammer and then Tonto is Johnny
Depp that's right all right
Rhys Ifans he's in the news this week
he's joining the James Bond film which
it right now is only called James Bond
what a surprise the loaded girl dropped
her drink on some people be careful
handle you're [ __ ] high Rhys Ifans is
joining the James Bond film which is
right now only called bond 23 but he has
joined the cast Javier Bardem and ray
Fiennes apparently are going to play the
villains in the piece no word on what
Rhys is going to play but rumor has it
he's gonna be the new cue the guy who
outfits him with all the new gadgets oh
really so they're finally gonna add that
element yes I met Rhys today he's the
lizard in the new amazing spider-man
so we did the panel today and we showed
a big chunk of lizard footage and we
brought him out and I see show footage
of the lizard oh yeah you saw with
Elizabeth a word and it's awesome didn't
bring a [ __ ] clip yeah
Sony was gonna let me walk out with a
clip from spider-man how did it look
compare it to something you know Killer
Croc in the Batman comics yeah yeah
that's the lizard now vibe okay most of
the traditional lizard which looked like
a lizard in a lab coat a lab coat yeah
this is much more Killer Croc kind of
vibe and when it's CGI'd and but it was
really very cool does it wear a purple
pants or no no now he is he's full-blown
monster no no pants whatsoever
they took his pants off yeah he's got a
giant lizard consciousness he's got like
two tails one in the front one in the
back so he's a guy he's like four leg
table man he's just sitting there right
Reese plays Curt Connors with the gimpy
arm in the whole nine yards and yeah it
was very cool and I said you know we
brought him out late because everyone
else was introduced and by the way
Andrew Garfield's sweetest guy on the
planet it couldn't have been nicer Emma
Stone as I mentioned had no [ __ ] idea
who I was and then Reese came out and I
said well he's late to the game I want
to try to include him give him his
moment in the panel try to you know
introduce him to the crowd and stuff so
I said Reese is an actor how do you
bring humanity to a monster because you
play a monster in this film and I don't
know whether he was high or drunk or
didn't like me but he said you don't
bring humanity to monsters monsters
bring humanity to us
and I said either he is the deepest
[ __ ] I've ever met or he wants
me to not ask him any more questions so
I erred on the side of caution I did a
panel today with William Shatner yeah
this morning I did a panel he directed a
documentary called the captains which
actually airs tonight on epics and it's
him talking to everybody who was ever a
captain on one of the ships in the
Starfleet on over the many Star Trek
shows right charming is [ __ ] they've
seen it and they showed clips in the
hall really really cool but on the panel
I got to play with him he's fun William
Shatner is a very sharp at 80 but is he
80 years old are you [ __ ] no he is
80 years old really yes I do dude I
didn't know he was 80
he's Mark [ __ ] really sharp but I was
at one point during the panel I got to
[ __ ] call double dumbass on you for a
guy who was a big fan of that Star Trek
movie it was [ __ ] huge it was fun it
was really how Liam Neeson's in the news
he was cast in a new movie leave parts I
imagine right he's his own co-star
trying to do hard news here man you're
making jokes you ain't getting the news
gonna be hard and when it gets hard
look out can never get off this island
Liam Neeson is gonna do movie called the
gray where he will play the leader of a
bunch of steel tough oil drillers yeah
come on grow up
how's he getting to that oil Ralph he's
gonna drill with a big drill bit they
crash land his crew crash lands in the
Alaskan wilderness on their way to a job
to the Alaskan pipeline hmm
apparently the crew has last compiled
eyes real long isn't it Ralph you're a
long and big and phallic like oh I don't
know Liam Neeson's guys the crew has to
fight to survive in the Alaskan
wilderness when they have a face-to-face
meeting with a wild Sarah Palin no
kidding no apparently it's about their
survival for battle apparently they
start to starve and so they just cut off
small pieces of his [ __ ] and they live
for 17 years in the wilderness feasting
on his [ __ ] is that what you people want
hey it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
I figure forever we gonna do an extended
geek news it would be this week oh my
God we're in geek News Haven biggest
geek news of the week was the success of
Deathly Hallows to the Harry Potter
movie it's breakin all kinds of [ __ ]
records one hundred and sixteen million
dollars in its opening weekend biggest
opening weekend ever in North America
total take around the world half a
billion dollars and its opening weekend
that I'm sorry did we upset you sir I
just I didn't like the film I'm walking
out
speaking of which Warner Brothers is so
happy with JK Rowling who really had
[ __ ] all to do with the movies in my
opinion I mean she wrote the book she
created the character but she wasn't
like she didn't direct him or anything
yes she wrote the book created the
characters but she didn't do [ __ ] off
for those movies well she didn't make
the movies um yeah she was she was she
was all over that [ __ ] man she deserves
all the credit for that well she
deserves more than credit Warner
Brothers to thank her the CEO of Warner
Brothers Barry Meyer wanted to buy her a
nice gift so he picked up an antique
white gold bracelet featuring 40 large
diamonds that was worth millions of
dollars they claim that's gonna cut into
that half a billion dollar take they had
this weekend she was said to his very it
was a very gracious gift JK said and she
accepted it she did she's like [ __ ] yes
they gave you a bracelet for cop out
didn't ya really they put me in
bracelets Daniel Radcliffe speaking
Harry Potter said he'd like to go back
and revisit the series in 50 years when
they're rebooting it like they're gonna
wait 50 yeah really man he said he'd
like to take a shot at Dumbledore he'd
like to play Dumbledore next time he
goes into that world so this time he can
molest the children instead of being
molested
Oh like Dumbledore wasn't [ __ ] just
grabbing those kids left and right come
on wake up people it's implicit there's
a subtext magic wands
hello forget a kiss indeed sir I wasn't
gonna say more Harry Potter chatter Lord
Voldemort I'm sorry the one who shall
not be named Rafe fine still gonna be
[ __ ] started on this [ __ ]
great finds
he's so finds why don't you let them
spell Rafe for me in this story Ralph
RAL pH it's [ __ ] Ralph that's what it
is don't oh no don't come here up call
me race race Garmin yeah just call you
rape how about that just making up names
now make up anything call me Steve my
tea I am Steve he's ashamed of Ralph
that's his problem
yeah somebody should be ashamed of he
said during the filming he used to wear
a garter belt under his robes as
Voldemort because the tights kept
slipping that makes him a little less
sinister doesn't it knowing he's wearing
women's underwear underneath those robes
the tights kept dropping between my
thighs it made it very hard for me to
walk with any kind of dignity so you put
on a garter belt to preserve your
dignity you know what we don't want you
Rafe we don't the rafts don't want you
anymore that's we've decided who kicked
him out of the Ralph's Club boom it just
happened
he's like I'm in my own club club race
and the Watson of Harry Potter she's in
talks to play the female lead and
Guillermo del Toro's new Beauty and the
Beast he's doing a take on that no word
yet on who will play the Beast however
producers are talking to Chelsea Handler
[Applause]
she's too hideous speaking of Chelsea
Handler I want to thank the person who
sent in the video they were anonymous
like I can't thank them by name but they
were anonymous and they have sent me a
video apparently there's a video game
out there where you it's a wrestling
video game and you can create your own
characters in the game and someone put
together a wrestling match between
myself and Chelsea Handler so again it's
a crapshoot but I brought him the video
of us battling it it's in two parts one
is us just fighting it out and then
another one apparently they gave me some
super power in the second half of the
fight that I use on her and I wanted to
show it to you because I think it's
pretty impressive I think we have the
video of that of me battling Chelsea
Handler in the wrestling ring if I were
to - I think that's it right there isn't
that there we go it's going Ralph versus
the talentless [ __ ]
[Music]
oh that's good that's a dropkick oh yeah
I kick around
better in a headlock
get her up again Oh donkey punch that's
not the first docking punch he's ever
had but here's my superpower Jack
Daniels breath Jack Daniels breath here
comes
[Applause]
knock her out with a jack breath god
bless all right we run on time so let's
say let's just do what we do at the end
of every show here in Hollywood
babble-on oh no really
yeah she's got the sign that they're
shining us off so it's time to get to
the question we asked at the end of
every Hollywood what pusher is that Rafe
why you I oughta
how big is Liam Neeson's [ __ ] there's
usually a [ __ ] no wait James one more
time
[Music]
I really should drink during the show
good move sir Kevin would you hold me
it'll all be over soon
no man we like the hiccups and bumps are
part of life part of the show and I
everyone's used to accustomed to that as
well Liam Neeson's [ __ ] you can go to
Neeson [ __ ] calm if you'd like to drench
your hoe jokes and add them to the list
we take a look at the list every week
and we pick out our favorites these are
some of them Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big there are three Starbucks between
the base and the tip
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he's
actually the sausage king of Chicago not
Abe Froman I should say you do by the
way I met that Nicolas Cage today did
the ghost ride the second Ghost Rider
movie was part of my panel you met him
did you do your night date I was like
Nick big fan I just wanna say I'm
looking forward to seeing the movie oh
right thanks he totally did it totally
did thirst and how on me really is a
little bit of thirst an hour at their
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big he doesn't have
a star on the Walk of Fame his [ __ ] has
its own walk of fame Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that every woman he [ __ ] gets
to walk a red carpet
oh yeah Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big the
Space Shuttle was decommissioned because
it's more cost-effective to toss a crew
onto Liam Neeson's [ __ ] and wait for him
to have an erection amid orbit Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big as they've
renamed the pro wrestling moves to the
half Neeson and the full nice and trust
me you never want the full Neeson Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that the only
things big enough to him - for him to
[ __ ] and not tear are the plot holes in
a transformer movie Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big you should never stand near it
during electrical storms Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big the Italians made a
small-scale model of it the Liam Tower
of Pisa Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
when he finishes having sex polar bears
drowned do the retreating surface area
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that to
keep it from destroying earth the crew
of the USS Enterprise had to travel back
to 1987 San Francisco to find another
one to communicate with it
[Music]
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that it
once made Gloria Steinem put on an apron
and make him a sandwich like Gloria
Steinem joke yeah that's bold in 2011
zaps here from the 70s Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that if you give him a
[ __ ] you will wind up with
Schindler's List Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is
so big it gives with lightning bolt
scars right above their cooter
[Laughter]
props just for working cooter into a
joke by the way
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big Khloe
Kardashian planks on it yeah mrs. [ __ ]
is so big that it went from the tide and
lost significant amount of weight to
start a new action comedy esoteric
Hollywood Jew Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that Carly Simon wrote a song for it
you're so veiny Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so
big that his biggest box-office success
was the time he turned a woman's box
into the size of a small office that was
it that was your last one that was it
usually wrap one of them up and the
finally Liam needs to Skyy I thought
there was one more to kill him
unprepared it's like you came before I
did sorry make one up quick okay and
finally Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that if you give him a [ __ ] you wind
up with Schindler's List
seems familiar did you guys have a good
time tonight thank you for being our
first Roadshow man no one is showing up
in droves like this thanks for listening
every week I appreciate it it's it's
been a blast so far and what with you
guys behind us man there's no telling
where we can go and we're going
someplace with the show soon so thank
you for listening all you guys tuning in
telling other people about the show
spreading the word is really helping it
grow into something else which we'll be
able to tell you about very very soon
thanks for being here tonight
thank you very sad am here with us every
week that's Hollywood babble-on for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
babble the [ __ ] on Comic Con good night
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen given up on garbage
[Music]
Hollywood babble-on
[Music]